brought to you by PlayStation view the
new live TV service now available on
your playstation over 100 channels no
annual contract game the system hey
folks Chris waters here on the front
lines at South by Southwest and I've
been touring these booths here in this
indie game area and multiple times
people have said Chris go play arena
God's oh my god arena God's arena God's
arena kazarina gods so mark let's talk
about arena God's man you are drawing
the crowds why do you think that is I
think you know people just really really
like carnage you know and I just I'm
just giving the people what they want
giving them what they want in this case
in a four player competitive local
combat it's a top-down view of
gladiators fighting it out in the arena
but the thing here is the combat system
so what do you guys sort of what's the
feel you're aiming for what are sort of
the pillars of your combat I think the
best way to describe it is holla Miami
meets zelda you know so like if you if
you met like if you're huge holly miami
fan and like real of holly miami and if
you play the game you can clearly see
the influence but you look at tower fall
and tower fall is basically a mario
battle arena and mario is great but we
were always really zelda fans and you
know remember like you know there would
be dueling sort of like you'd fight the
minibosses and stuff but like like we
always manage like dude what if that was
another player like what if like you
could have two links fight each other
but you know we never really we got a
cooperative Zelda game but we didn't
really get vs and so like for me the
dream is and we're not quite there yet
remember the ball and chain night that
you had a fight yeah we want you to be
able to be the ball and chain night
alright so let's talk ball and chain
let's talk trident this is a gladatorial
scene and so weapons are in play in
there a huge factor totally um so our
favorite FPS hands down is quake three
alright quake 3 arena like that's that's
that's our damn that's our jam but we
also love vanquish like a lot of people
forget about vanquish and sleep on
vanquishment dude dude like don't don't
even let me I got such lidded hold it it
arena gods
but um so like the two like something
that's really big in both games is
controlling weapon pickups and where
they come from and that's something we
don't think we've nailed it yet and
we're leading kind of more towards
vanquished in this sense but we want it
to very much be about how there's not
necessarily a better weapon but there's
a best weapon per each scenario for the
context and you can carry up to two so
your strengths in like your pros and
cons your strengths and weaknesses
change on the fly based upon the weapons
you have the weapons your opponents have
and the new weapons that are coming up
into the arena through the floor doors
and they come up and they change the
landscape totally I mean you've got
Spears you've got swords and not only
can people thrust with these can they
have one in each hand or have a shield
as well but you're also throwing them
around the map and I was both the
beneficiary of and the victim of
throwing it out one side of the map and
having it come in the other side so
really doing a lot to make this a
dynamic battlefield for sure I mean when
all things are said and done like our
hope is that you have this game where
whether you're unarmed or arms whether
you're holding a sword or somebody
severed arm and I'm not kidding that
it's as much a game about improvisation
as much as it is about for lack of a
better word vainglory you know you know
stabbing yourself in your own back I
literally did that it was embarrassing
but our ultimate goal though is that
we're building this as a gladiatorial
games for gladiators right and that's
why we love like the first batman arkham
asylum if you guys remember that like
they're been Batman games before that
but that was like the first batman game
where like maybe after five minutes in
you were like I'm Batman yeah like I'm
Batman and that's exactly what we want
to do and but something that is probably
most important to us is you know
remember we're like you know we were
talking about this earlier you know
remember as a kid that first game you
play where you find the invisible wall
and it's such a disappointment I want to
go there can't go there can't go there
or like Oh everything's destructible
wait the lamp post is not destructible
you know you can paint everything but
the painting
and that like that chipped away at us
like over time and now as adults were
like cynical you know well what farina
gods we have this rare opportunity where
you know the because our universe is the
arena hence arena gods we want to make
sure that if it's something that you
want to do within reason you know we're
not going to let you crap watermelons
but it's rude well talk we'll talk um
that you can do it you know like his
head goes flying why can't I use I head
as a weapon you know why can't I throw
that head as well you know why can't I
wear it in a little problem while you
wear the head but you know I can't i
where the head alright that's too far
your ambition ah it's impressive I'm
excited to see where you guys go with
this you've clearly got some great ideas
in the mix and you've clearly like
really dialed something in here it's
resonating with the crowds at South by
Southwest I do you have any idea of like
when this game might be coming out or
are we still too far from there to be
frankly honest earliest 2016 ladies 2017
all right a little bit longer before you
folks can be an arena GABA man when you
can so good
you